Turmoil spreading tonight at Twitter
where there appears
to be
some kind of a mass
exodus of workers who are reject
Elon Musk's ultimatum to work
extremely hard core,
which are
defined simply
as long hours at high intensity.
But how many hours and how highl
what does that mean?
Well, no one knows.
But a lot of employees
apparently didn't care
to wait to find out.
And they just said goodbye
to NW senior media reporter Oliv
Is here with more.
Oliver, there's a lot happening.
Seems every other day
on Twitter,
a mass exodus now appears to be
and they're rejecting that 5 p.m
deadline of today, that ultimatu
And now I hear
they're closing their office bui
Why?
What do you hear people say to T
Yeah, it really feels like
Twitter is taking its last gasp
I mean,
if you look on Twitter right now
the top trend worldwide is R.I.P
Twitter.
And that's because scores of emp
have seemingly resigned
from Twitter rejecting
Elon Musk's ultimatum.
Let's let's let's take viewers b
Musk earlier
this week
gave Twitter
workers, the people who are rema
after those mass layoffs.
Earlier this month,
he gave them a choice
work, quote unquote, hard core o
leave the company
with three months of severance
it seems like a large amount of
have decided to leave the compan
They don't want to work hard cor
And that's throwing the future
of this platform into utter chao
I've been talking to people all
One former executive
who recently exited told me that
with all these departures, it's
going to be hard
just to keep the lights on over
And so now with all these depart
the people who are manning
the management has suspended
badge access
into Twitter's offices,
presumably because they're afrai
that employees
who are technically
no longer employed at Twitter
could potentially sabotage thing
I'll read you the statement or t
they sent to staffers.
It says,
Effective immediately,
we are temporarily
closing our office buildings and
batch access to will be suspende
Offices will reopen on Monday
November 21st.
And it goes on to say,
we look forward to working with
on Twitter's future.
But as you can see, just mass di
has gripped this company here.
I mean, you say this and talk
about the lights coming on,
I think, to myself.
What about security?
One of the who's
guarding the henhouse,
who's ensuring
that even operates
and functions in any meaningful
But there's also this moment
that you're talking about,
this hard core intently.
He seemed to soften his stance,
on getting rid of remote work
just earlier
today is the latest wall
backtrack and his plan.
I mean, I wonder how this whipla
is really landing
and affecting people
who are still at Twitter,
still employed,
maybe waiting until Monday to fi
if they're back to work again.
Everyone is confused
that that's that's the short ans
And I was told earlier today
that management was really worri
that they weren't
going to be able to retain talen
They were really
I think it was becoming clear
that a lot of employees
were actually just going
to leave Twitter altogether.
And so some
sources told me
that they were scrambling,
trying to get people to stay in.
Elon Musk seemed to recognize th
I'll read you part of a note
he sent to the entire company
when he softened his stance on
remote work.
He said earlier today,
where is that?
I had to hear regarding remote w
all that is required for approva
is that your manager
take responsibility for ensuring
that you are making
an excellent contribution.
And he went on to explain
that basically people could
work remotely if if management o
And recently,
I think you're even seeing Musk
some of this news.
He just tweeted moments ago abou
how you turn a large fortune
into a small one.
And it is on screen.
How do you make a small fortune
in social media?
Start out with a large one,
really kind of putting into cont
what's happened to his $44 billi
purchase of the company?
Wow.
And you've got to add,
at the end of that,
discussion about remote work,
the idea of, hey,
by the way, of any
of the employers
who are supposed to essentially
that you are working,
if they're not truthful, Goodbye
I mean, you have this sort of co
language of
not even coded in that instance,
but the idea of that new tweet.
Wow, a lot of chaos happening th
Oliver, nice to see you.
We'll see how long Twitter stays
I will hold my breath.